man you know what was cool about the red
light district that this is like the the
time where i i tried like um basically
sex workers is my only time
but when i was there
i remember like you go down these side
streets just a bunch of windows
therefore it's kind of it's trippy in a
way it's like a playground yeah it's
kind of [ __ ] up yeah candy store yeah
and every time you look you take a
little side street there's like more
women in different spots and they all
look different big women small women
black women
short women big titties fake titties
everything you want and you can just see
them in the windows stone they're
bikinis it's kind of like it's the
greatest window shopping i've ever seen
yeah because you get what you want
but i never forget this i'm like behind
four or five dudes
and i'm with my homie we're talking
we're at the back of these guys yeah and
they're in front of us and they turn
into a corner and we turn into the side
street and as i look into my homie i
look back in front and like two of them
have disappeared and then i look back to
my home they were still one floor and i
talked and i looked back and they're all
gone and each of them had just gone into
one of the doors like just disappeared
fast like that
really yeah it was really trippy they
just went the [ __ ] yeah
they knew exactly where they were going
how fast the street emptied
okay yeah they you exactly who they knew
ahead like okay yeah they knew who they
wanted to go to this girl here yeah yeah
yeah it was just fast how like quickly
the side street disappeared so it's just
like a big ass building there's all like
windows it's a bunch of buildings think
of it like old port you know how there's
like just buildings everywhere but you
know there's also like shitty side
streets well even the shitty slice we've
got window stills there's some people on
the main street some people on the side
street all kinds of stuff and light and
like some of them like you need the
stairs and it's just a bunch of like
windows and you and they're like neon
red on the outline of the window and
there's the women just steaming out the
window is there a competition
oh like like a hierarchy
i'm a big window [ __ ] i'm a slasher
[ __ ]
probably i imagine that
based off who's running you because i'm
sure there's people who are running this
place
you get specific windows based on how
much money you can make because certain
student gets more traffic logically i'm
assuming this i don't know for sure
um but yeah you'll find you'll find
everything any type of woman that you
want though
yeah well i mean i mean i don't know if
it's dope there's a lot of trafficking a
lot of women from easter it's crazy a
lot of women from eastern europe get
traffic there so it's important to
remember that i know
yeah i feel like legalizing it right or
at least decriminalizing probably
lessens the amount of that right well i
don't know if it listens but at least
people that get trafficked or people
that uh something happens to them have a
recourse
so it's more so like if someone a client
is violent like you know something that
happened the other day here from with a
sex worker from quebec city and then she
came here got a client a claim that
every sex worker knew
and he was known to be violent
actually the son
of uh
vermont bagels anyway
damn yeah and he went there killed us
the sex worker and
one off himself
oh [ __ ] i gotta start going to san diego
now [ __ ] it
the problem with the whole sex work
thing and the recourse is that when
you're trafficked it's not enough to be
able to have legal authorities like if
they target your family back home your
siblings you can't really do much yeah
you can't pass people you can't do much
so it's not it's not simple it's not
easy you get away it's like they know
everybody you know back home but you
can't do what you want you can't go talk
to the police we'll kill them yeah you
know what i'm saying so kill everybody
um yeah even if i am for legalization of
this stuff because i do think it would
be overall safer there's still
tremendous amount of danger in from what
i read up on
where it happens um yeah there's still a
lot of downsides for it to be vigorous
and actually over here
most sex workers i've met do not want it
legalized
no they wanted one
there you go different they don't want
to legalize no legalize means that you
have legislative legislation over that
right and it's still the same people
that got the same power and stuff like
that legalized mean that there is
legalities to it that needs to
push your [ __ ] in the real reason is
they don't want to pay taxes
that's what i said
[Music]
they don't want to pay taxes taxes do
they like that tax free buddy